December of 2019 is going to be a fateful
time for Netflix, with Disney+ having gone
live in the middle of November.
Here are few titles jumping from to Disney
in December, plus a few more leaving Netflix
not owned by the House of Mouse.
If you haven't seen this particular Marvel
Cinematic Universe offering yet, now's as
good a time as any.
The third installment of the Thor series is
one of the higher-rated and more widely acclaimed
installments in the entire MCU.
Even those who typically don't get into superhero
films tend to make an exception for this one,
with its expert blend of action, heart, and
humor.
"Wanna use a big wooden fork?"
"No."
"Yeah, not really useful, unless you were
fighting off three vampires that were huddled
together."
As with all MCU films, it does help to have
seen a few others before diving into Ragnarok,
but the film is a fairly well-contained story
that outside context only enhances, rather
than being a necessity.
Directed by Taika Waititi, Ragnarok sees the
God of Thunder learning some new and uncomfortable
hidden truths about Asgardian history and
his father, Odin.
A conflict with a new and powerful enemy sends
Thor to the secret world of Sakaar, ruled
over by the Grandmaster, and home to his ruthless
gladiator games.
Along with old friends and new alliances,
Thor must survive and find a way to flee Sakaar
to save his homeland from the threat of Ragnarok,
the prophecy that foretells the destruction
of the entire Asgardian race.
Thor: Ragnarok will be leaving Netflix on
December 4th.
With a box office take of $1.3 billion, there
aren't many sci-fi fans left who haven't seen
Star Wars: The Last Jedi at least once.
If you somehow missed it, this is probably
the last opportunity to stream it on a third-party
platform before it reemerges on Disney+ forevermore.
Writer/director Rian Johnson makes a concerted
effort to both enrich Star Wars lore, and
to play with expectations, giving fresh perspectives
of what we know about the Jedi and the universe
in which Star Wars exists.
"The Force is not a power you have.
It's not about lifting rocks, it's the energy
between all things."
The Last Jedi immediately picks up where The
Force Awakens left off, with Rey beginning
a proper education in the use of the Force.
In doing so, she'll discover many truths about
the Jedi, Luke Skywalker, and his relationship
with Kylo Ren.
Meanwhile, division begins to roil within
the Resistance, and the First Order is on
the hunt, hoping to destroy the Resistance's
high command at last.
As Rey begins to realize that nothing is what
it seems, how will she go forward, both for
her own sake and that of the Resistance?
Star Wars: The Last Jedi leaves Netflix on
December 25th.
Seeing the 1982 feature The Dark Crystal before
it leaves Netflix is of particular importance
if you have watched, or want to get around
to watching, Netflix's revival series The
Dark Crystal: Age of Resistance.
The modern series is set well before the events
of the film, and chronicles the downfall of
the world and near-extinction of the species
known as the Gelfling.
The movie may be going away, but not necessarily
forever.
Jim Henson's Muppet works and characters are
owned by Disney, but The Dark Crystal film
and its characters are owned entirely by The
Jim Henson Company, which is still an independent
studio.
The license will likely be re-upped at some
point in the future, especially if a second
season of the revival series is greenlit.
As for the film, The Dark Crystal, directed
by Jim Henson and Frank Oz, is a high-fantasy
story about the planet Thra, a world on the
edge of total destruction.
A thousand years before, the evil vulture-like
Skeksis shattered a magic crystal in order
to use it for themselves as a source of eternal
life.
Thra's last living Gelflings, Jen and Kira
[KEE-rah], undertake a quest to find the missing
shard and heal the crystal in hopes of destroying
the Skeksis and returning Thra to its former
thriving and lush green state.
The Dark Crystal departs Netflix on December
31.
Schindler's List likely needs no introduction;
the 1993 historical drama appeared on Leonard
Maltin's list of the 100 most important films
of the 20th century and won a small avalanche
of awards, including six Oscars.
Directed by Steven Spielberg, the film is
an adaptation of the historical fiction novel
Schindler's Ark.
While it depicts actual events, and the central
characters did exist, some of the narrative
lacks firm historical record and has been
filled in with supposition.
The film tells the story of Oskar Schindler,
a factory owner who saved over a thousand
Jewish people from death at the hands of the
Nazi regime by trafficking them through his
business.
Schindler begins as a faithful Nazi party
member enjoying status among the SS, employing
Jews recruited from the ghetto for cheap labor.
When the ghetto is purged, however, the violence
is so extreme that Schindler's allegiance
is forever altered.
Afterwards, he begins working with his Jewish
business partner in secret to secure the safety
of as many Jews as possible.
Schindler's List will leave Netflix on December
31.
Wet Hot American Summer, released in 2001
to underwhelming reviews and a brutal box
office, has developed a reputation as a nostalgic
cult classic in the years since.
Part of that is due to a talented cast that's
only gone on to huge success in the intervening
years since the film's release.
Among them are Christopher Meloni, David Hyde
Pierce, Janeane Garofalo, Paul Rudd, Amy Poehler,
and many more.
The film focuses on the last day of summer
camp at the fictional Camp Firewood in 1981,
where the various kids and camp counselors
fall in love, get into hijinks, and plan talent
shows...
"It sounds like pretty well-worn territory."
"The whole thing feels kinda trite.
I say we forget it."
"Is that how everyone feels?"
"Yeah."
Well, they also try to save the camp from
being crushed by a piece of NASA's Skylab
that happens to be plummeting through Earth's
atmosphere.
Wet Hot American Summer will also be departing
from Netflix on December 31.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.